i'm going to start this episode with a
complaint something that's been
wrangling me a little bit lately which
is icy drinks
now we do a podcast and we work with
these very uh sensitive microphones i
don't know when this is going to be
airing but it won't oh this will air
this will see the light of day i will be
heard i uh i was talking to
let's just knock it off i was talking to
uh a comedy icon uh someone who i really
adore and i was looking forward to this
interview and throughout the interview
you were the worst defender matt you
kept you have what looks to be an an ice
it's like a pink drink what is it just a
uh unsweetened passion tree yeah right
but it's mostly ice and i'd be talking
to this person and you should be saying
something really emotional like yeah
it's true through this really tough time
and then i'd hear here do it sona and
then i'd hear this i'd hear that in the
background i'd look over and you're
taking a big old gulp i saw you look at
me oh i looked at you several times and
it didn't stop you
well i couldn't tell if you were just
looking to see what that was or you're
trying to send me a signal so i have a
request i know plastic straws are out
yeah we don't want to be killing any
dolphins with plastic straws
but i will pay
for you two to get uh metallic straws of
your choice
um this is a tough thing for me because
when you say something bugs you i just
want to do it more i know and i i know
you have a legitimate complaint let me
see this this is literally we do a lot
of we do a lot of jokes and a lot of fun
stories on this podcast that's really
nice but sometimes you're talking to
somebody and it gets real
and they start talking about something
they start talking about something like
yeah it was really rough for me because
um
you know i remember
i'm like um
i was really close to my
grandfather and i'm like
and then one day
i went to his room
and
i
he's doing the laundry i just
and i'm like what i'm my grandfather he
came here
and i'm having trouble even
understanding what they're saying and
i'm so distracted put a goddamn straw in
the drink can i say you're working on my
own i when my defense i waited until
that guest drank her own iced coffee
before and i cannot control the guests
okay if a guest shows up and has an iced
coffee there's little i can do i think
it might be a smart idea and i i think
you're the behind the scenes whiz
putting this whole thing together matt
so if you
maybe have thought to have some straws
here and supply the guests with the
straw so they at least have the option
but i can't control them you i can
control i didn't know there were gonna
be drinks i didn't even ask for a drink
it was nice enough to david to bring one
in the first place david brought this
yes david get in here david this is
david hopping because we all know sona
needs an assistant to do the work she's
not doing how dare you uh david have a
seat right here if you will that is true
is uh mike
this mic on he's not he's not
oh
our engineer ran away he's printing your
ads oh actually he told me to say this
okay that's great
david
you no one asked you for icy drinks and
you supplied them
well the guest that was on requested a
drink right and then you saw it i'll
just get um
i'll just go well this is what matt got
uh wednesday so i thought he might want
it again i'm not throwing you under the
bus david that was no no no no no no no
no no no no you made it gesture you made it
quick i always call i always call you i
said do you want any starbucks then i
call sona and then i didn't have your
number in my phone but i just got you
one yeah well i have had his number for
a long time and i know what he's up to
he's up to it's called pulling focus in
show business matt wants to make it
about himself in some small way and you
saw me really vibing with a guest
we had it we were in the groove it was
going to be
this is probably the interview that's
going to get me a peabody award and you
couldn't handle it could you matt so you
could handle it it was probably no big
deal literally it sounds like three lab
skeletons falling down a flight of steps
i don't want to make excuses but this is
literally my 10th podcast this week and
i'm a bit fried so get off my back the
man yeah you know what uh adam brought
something up slash he said slash was
doing it during his interview he slashed
and you called him out on it and how
[ __ ] dare you
call out slash on anything first of all
i don't care who it is oh no no no no i
don't care who it is and i i adore slash
i adore slash and um check out that
episode it's a really good one um but
plugging
there was so much ice rattling it it
really did sound it really did sound
like the titanic had just hit the bird
there was ice exploding all over the
place
and so
the reason i called you in david is
because what you basically did was you
weaponized the podcast you brought
um weaponizer brought joy yeah broad joy
this is delicious it's actually really
good we had never had it we had it
because matt got it the other day thank
you thank you maybe you should just try
the drink and then we can all have noisy
ice drinks on no thanks
i'm good
and also um i live off hate i have a
vast reserve of hate inside my body yeah
and i draw on it at any time i could not
eat food and live for a thousand years
that hydrates you you don't need
beverages it does everything it hydrates
it provides caloric energy
um yeah just and it's i'm talking about
just about six years from 1972 to 1978 i
can live off that hate good so healthy
you know what it's done fine by me oh
okay and i'll tell you something else
david you're not to bring them okay
you're not to bring them icy drinks
anymore what if we get a straw thinking
they have it all right but i don't want
to hear
matt gourley i do not want to hear ice
rattling around and don't tell me you
saw me looking at you didn't you and
what was what was that glare like like i
said i think it was like oh is he just
just hearing the noise and looking over
to see what the noise is but then it was
just a fraction of a second long enough
to go oh no he hates me yeah that's
right yeah that's why i hold for that
fraction of an extra second there's a
lot of thought that goes into my deadly
glares yeah but it didn't change your
behavior i noticed you kept slurping in
a slurpee but i wanted to give you the
benefit of the doubt well
you were wrong
i'm just as petty as you thought i was
there's no more ice no more rattling ice
on this show i'm shutting it down okay
okay hopping next time they want
something to drink get them some maple
syrup and a paper
[Laughter]
my god
caesar has spoken